I'm excited to show you the original version of days in the sun
It starts with the prince's mother played by Harriet Jones
Singing her favorite lullaby to her son who lies in the sick bed
Later, it's the mother who's in bed. She's just died
And the young prince is pulled away by his father
We re-shot this, you know, because of a mistake I made
When we previewed the movie, there were people in the audience who got confused
They thought Harriet was actually Hattie Morahan
Who plays Agathe the enchantress
The actresses actually look very much alike so sadly when we did it again
Even though it is once again Harriet, we had to put her in bed, and with dark hair
Sadly, it meant we had to recast the boy because in the new version it was now a singing part
And we needed someone with a trained voice
I'm thrilled to able to finally share what I thought was a wonderful
Really lovely performance from Harriet Jones in this clip
music
Rest now, my love
Days in the sun, where your life has barely begun
Not until my own life is done, could I ever leave you